c'est une amy coni bar est presque sûre
d'être confirmée à la tête de la cour
suprême qui s'est présenté devant le
comité judiciaire du sénat américain ce
lundi sauf grosse surprise
la magistrate conservatrice de 48 ans
nommé par donald trump fin septembre
devrait succéder à ruth bader ginsburg
au terme de quatre jours d'audience car
les démocrates qui fustigent cette
nomination à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle ont peu de
levier pour l'empêcher un passage en
force qui laisse un goût très amer aux
opposants à cette nomination d'autant qu
amy coni barrette cje rahabi les
républicains eux louent les qualités de
la magistrate
au delà des considérations de politique
sur la première fois dans l'histoire des
états unis
un président sortant refuse de s'engager
dans une transition pacifique du pouvoir
s'il perd les élections ce président
dans sa vanité et son insouciance
constitutionnel refuse de s'engager à
accepter la volonté de l'électorat
américain
nous avons permis la politisation de la
seule branche du gouvernement fédéral
qui n'est pas politique
nous pouvons renverser la situation
nous mêmes au sein de la branche
législative devons faire un meilleur
travail en mettant l'accent sur le fait
que la constitution n'est pas seulement
une affaire judiciaire c'est aussi une
question législatives
c'est aussi une question de direction
c'est une affaire américaine
à l'extérieur le bras de fer fait rage
entre pro et anti barrette deux
manifestations se sont tenues au même
moment au même endroit ce lundi matin à
washington avant le début de l'audition
et ce genre de rassemblement pourrait se
renouveler toute la semaine les pros
barrette devrait néanmoins avoir gain de
cause car les républicains ont
l'avantagé du nombre et dispose d'une
majorité de 53 sièges sur 100 à la
chambre haute du congrès seul le kobe 19
pourrait menacer le calendrier
trois sénateurs républicains ont été
testés positifs l'un d'entre eux s'est
dit prêt à se rendre en séance plénière
en tenue d'astronautes si nécessaire